I'm having gut aches after eating. Is this a side of food allergies?
It can be typically if you have antibodies, so you talk about allergies. You're talking about
that you have antibodies, IgG and IgA antibodies, to different proteins in food usually.
Now, if you had an IgE antibodies to a food, that would be like peanut allergy where you could
you know, you need an epiped to deal with this because you could go into, you know,
bronchial constriction in this allergic type reaction. We're talking IgG and IgA antibodies to
different peptides and proteins in food. If you have food allergies, will you get an instant
ache in your gut after eating? Sometimes, quite honestly, usually not. So usually those reactions
take hours to even a day for you to have. So it is kind of difficult to identify food allergies simply
by your symptoms because the gut pain that you might be getting could be what you ate last
night. Well, no, I'm having gut pain right after I eat. Well, there's other reasons why you'd have
gut pain right after you eat. That is nothing to do with having antibodies against that food. Most
common reason for having gut pain after eating is the deficiency in hydrochloric acid. Second,
most common reason would go right along with that is that they have insufficiency of digestive enzymes
for the patients. So that's why I suggest everybody take HCl and digestive enzymes with their meal
because this is a common symptom that people get. They have, they feel bloated after they eat,
they get gut pain after they eat, they feel like they have a full tummy, just eat a little bit,
they get stomach ache after they eat, all these different symptoms that go along with
mal digestion. So again, mal digestion is probably the double one morbidity in the world that could lead
to all sorts of problems. So hypochloridria and decrease pancreatic enzyme production
is the cause of that. So supporting that would be the first thing I would think. So if somebody says,
I really think I should do a food allergy panel and getting gut pain after I eat my first question
would be are you taking HCl and digestive enzymes? Well, no, I haven't really taken those. Well,
that's what I would do first before I do a food sensitive panel.